Yes, I am
participating in every taping under the title of the open source project a, and now I am here to share what I have learned.
Work
Goyo
no 2 It is a test framework that can be used in both Jace and web browsers. It's
been quite a while now, so it's been developed together since the early days of Node, and it
can be seen as a cocoon project like Node ecology.
So, this is now called the State of JavaScript every year.  It's a
site that surveyed the JavaScript ecosystem, but if you
look last year, you can see that Zest is now used the most, followed by
Mocha.  You can see that
the color has come up. You may not be able to see the color well for 9 minutes from the back.  I've
never heard of it. It's about 9 minutes long like this.
When I confirmed that this
weekend, about 870,000 projects are now in use, and the star
is currently filming about 18,000.
So  Now, when I first talk about it, I
think I should start with how I came to join as a maintainer.
I think you'll be very curious about that part.
I joined org for the first time.  As you
can see at the time of the requirements for crafters, when you look at it in January of 2018, content 3 was completely different at that time.  I
left the company, so at the beginning of the year and the end of the year, I was thinking about
living in a company of 40,000 pyeong for one to two or three
months, and I couldn't just waste two or three months of break time, so
now I study something and do something else.  But now I was diligently looking for an open source control cushion and
gearing up. That
's why the graph you saw earlier came out.
Before that, I had been using Mocha for a long time, and Mocha was also the
target.
Of course, even before this time, I was there where I was uploading pr from time
to time.
I did 5 gears, but only 5 of them were done in February.
Before that, in the old days, I was betting on something simple, then 1, then rhema. Now I made 5 commits and
uploaded PIA.
It seems that it was a single to increase the main tenor now.
Yes, it is difficult to see from the outside now, and now that I go in and continue to look at the project, I
feel a bit like that now, but while working together,
cotton is a community-based open source project  What I said is
community-based is that now we
don't have a full-time open source full-time atman tenor. Everyone has
their own job, their own life, and most of them are only people who come home from work and play Boca as the main tank separately, and
now there are vendors.  In addition to supporting, in the
case of the head act, I think that the
way we proceed will be a little different because Facebook pays a lot of money for this kind of thing now, and now we hire full-time developers and do
it.
Of course, just because the community is moving around ticks
doesn't necessarily mean that there aren't
full-time motors developers.
So let's do open source development, so let's get it. Yes, I did 5 on Com earlier in February.  It
has become noticeable now. There are
too many people who go back and forth like this once or twice, so I just
don’t remember that very much, but now, in a short period of time, people who come like this three or four times, four or five times,
or people who exchange p-al comments, remember Amen.
If there was a time when we thought we should increase the number of people like that, we
made a big proposal for those people, so they joined again, and even after us, about one or two people
came in that way.  There
are about 10 members in our core team right now, but I've
never seen 5 of them, 1 year old or 4.
So now, if you want to reduce the number of co-members,
but if someone else wants to work hard again, now I'm
going back to this way by making a proposal again and mixing it together.
This was great.
Uh, this was open source before, now it's a personal side
project, now it's a kit that everyone knows, and
there are developers who are good at it, and how much can I learn from these people?  And
a year and a half has passed. A year and a half is the same as mine.
And the thing I felt the most was that he was busy with his comments.  has
become open source now, but I
received pi again, received issue reports, and tried it while talking to people with it.
As a member of the ecosystem, I
have now made a presentation on what developers should do elsewhere. Well, at that time, of course, I was busy with momentum and I was talking about things like that.  I
have a feeling that I am so busy that I have to pay attention to what I am doing.
So when I look at something, the tower is now a notification, so now Beethoven's notification keeps going for
5 seconds.
There are about 100. I wake up when there are many.
Hey, Mocha. It's not that big, so it's not that
many.
Mocha is not at that level anymore. This is like 5 sets. Then, the two worlds come.
Now, for a day or two, I take a break or have a party or something, so if I miss it,
it continues to accumulate that much
every day.  If you come home from work in the evening and say you
need to do mocha now, go in and click on it.
What and how it is composed and what is
selected is all about the content,
and now we have to label it.  It's
easy to label so that it's easy to understand.
Labeling is now what's broken, what is the node, what is the category aging,
and other than that, what additional information is needed, whether the
bug has been confirmed, etc.
Then, the reason I can solve it is that issues are now commented, issues with opinions are
commented, and what
seems to be on the screen is that I have now commented and closed with a
jockey.  I didn't know how to use it myself,
so I posted it as a mocha issue, but in fact, it's not a mocha issue, but the way to use Nodu
itself is wrong.
When I upload it, as I said before,
read the entire article, look at the example code or this, find the problem now,
run it, and if I find the correct answer,
I'll post it.  and Mocha is a
test framework, so there are people who test Karma, and some
people are polishing it with Babel, and it
looks like a map.  It takes 30 minutes, and if it's long, it
seems to take up to an hour or two.
Then, in order to reduce those things, man tenors now
ask for a gem cv if there are not many governments, or
ask for more as additional information, and uh,
we test them one by one  I can't try it, so if I imagine it's lacking in , I'll do
something like this. Now,
what's like mcv? Now, there's a stack overflow off-help document.  Now you
're doing it, you're paying for several codes, but if you create the smallest example that can completely control the problem situation,
now
you can know if you just run the main tag as soon as you receive it, and most of them are provided to a high degree, you
can know that you don't have to receive it  Because there are so many cases, you can save a lot of time.
And when you step back from that notification, it's now a p discount.
Now you have to do a code review.  After
figuring it out,
reading what was discussed there, and reading how that person tried to fix it in the precast that came back to avoid pr, and
then look at the code together and now
give your opinion about it.
First of all, I'm talking about the missing part,
and I'm not the only one who comments now. I have to
write my code.
I have to write my own code.
Things that don't belong to Cushion Country m What should be discussed? After work, roadmap pay or release guts,
when we have questions, we discuss via chat now, but this
happens almost every week now.  I think I have to spend time to
feel like I'm almost following the pace.
Of course, if I miss a day, the burden will be bigger the next time.
Why don't you blame the issue, please don't post an answer in the future I'm
replying to something that no one is interested in but I'm too busy to see it all.  You
won't see it next time
And looking at it up close, this main trend is that this kind of project doesn't have only one.
Because of that, there is no more time.
As a result, most of the activities inside the main panel of the Mac
seem to be set up so that Materna can be active for a long time.
Most of the so-called busy clothes are focused on being able to go all the way, and we try hard not to put pressure on each other like this and
not to feel the schedule pressure.  They
keep calling and
talking, but there's no blaming or anything like that, and if you
just keep watching most of them, you're running it just to the extent that you just watch it according to your own schedule and
take a little more time when you have time.  It's
not going to end, so
uh, rather, suddenly run in bo crunch mode.  Yes,
because it's open source,
and now that I've seen all the commits, there are people who are rude
to this party, and now I'm properly warning
them.  Now I'm talking about that.
Now, to briefly summarize, now, I know it's difficult because the function is missing at the time, but hey,
all of these projects are people who voluntarily participate, so
don't be so sarcastic or say it in the way it requires.  That way, I
'm working while setting the guidelines to some extent now.
Also, now that I'm working on the development like this, I've
been talking about the content before, but I think it's very important to have a relaxed mindset now.
I think I have to do some training and try not to do it.
Besides before, when I was working on a personal project, I felt very pressured when Schultz first received it
because I think I made a mistake and the client is going to fall apart, so
I want to fix it quickly, and I just like that.  I felt the pressure, but
now I thought I was trained for that kind of thing, but now it's kind of
okay.  So in the end,
open source means that someone who thinks it's urgent and important
just needs to upload an American code.  If this is too urgent, then you
have to come up with the code, discuss it, persuade it, and put it in.
Now, the main tenor or mob has to hit it and solve it, and it's
not a relationship like this.
When I put it in, it now becomes a
matte, and it is one of the options I put in at the beginning, do you know or avoid
it, but after about 6 months,
it has now turned into a roll.  There
was a lot of discussion about the Lotte car after the sun went down and the mouth was gone, but then they got rid of it.
Then they rolled back and there was one more like this.  Because I keep
doing lol, I feel like a person shrinks.
I'm taller than Mr. I
can't do it, but I'm a little scared of doing it, and it's not like that, but I'm asking for it to be
increased little by little.
But I just set the pattern I set and use it and
keep using it. I don’t use it every month while rotating through all the options.
Before n10, there are quite a few things I didn't even know existed without this.
After that, I can't do all the bases, I just do what I can contribute.  I write a
little bit of what I can see and structure it, and it takes time to do all of those things anyway, so
we focus on those things, and I
'm catching up now by spending time on the core part and studying little by little.  The
competition is very fierce.
This is why people say that they
like open source because they do things like who do people like?
It is said that
one of our comms once posted this issue. Last year,
now Zest is popping up these days, and we also have hip function snapshots like Zest,
coverage, and things like
that.  So
now a little more Now all the sources did this year Now the main tag They appeared and
wrote this The contents of the station briefly explained, now Mocha does
not affect Zest and does not give Zest Voca zero We just catch it and
test the test environment in the skid ecosystem  The
goal of our universe is to create a good environment so that more can accumulate g. We
wrote the story that it is not a problem for each other, and
Christopher Lee, the creator of Zest, was also summoned and now
called, so here is also a long article.  I, who played the role, feel a little depressed whenever I see this kind of writing.
Zest thinks that cotton is not competing with each other, and that it is
not okay for one side to suffer or become a problem for the other to become successful.  I
think this article was a bit impressive to me by reaching a test framework that is different and has its own area.  I hope it
gets better and
there are things like this,
but I thought that it was not necessary because of the open source ecology that I had done with teaching materials.  It
was fine to skip the issues I didn't understand because
I couldn't do hacks, and I could solve them, and I just had to understand them and
deal with them.  Since you become a tenor, you
have to see all issues and participate in all discussions. So, now that you
follow the context, it takes a lot of time and is very difficult even if you can't forget 100% of them to some extent.  If it
leads to a discussion, then there are opinions.
Now I just say simple words, I
added Lux ​​and moved on, and I went on with Uggle. A little bit,
actually, I didn't do it, but I
didn't
do it.
And now, I do
n't know what I didn't know about the turn.
There's an error, so I keep putting humanity on issues that have already been closed.
But for maintainers, this is a huge button because
most of the old ones have long threads, and
I click and enter this article, which has 38 threads, for example.
At the bottom, it says "I also have this error, this structure", but even if the gun of the avant-garde
goes up, I
have to read it all. What is this?  I've
never seen anything like Mocha Haeseon. So no matter
how much I write there, it can't be reopened. Yes, that's why
we posted this.  Let's
not let that happen because I'm young so I can't ride the
gloves Now let's leave this now The origin is now making rice Now
Henry wrote a similar story That's too main convenience Because I'm defending the time It's
time to get hurt and when it's time, it's now an automation script Roda thread
However, rather than leaving a post in the closed thread, it is much better to
create 3 issues and then bring up a list of why there are problems in the current finals
after the wrinkles.
Because there is no way to know whether we are using the old version or whether we are the only ones who wrote the same thing, we
just skip it.  It's a framework that I like, and I
can move on to another Franco for 4 problems that I
don't like.
I only have to request a feature, so I request that this is necessary, but now when I receive it, I
think a lot now.  We have to
talk about whether there is a problem with other functions by putting it in, and this exorbitant sea that each of us has to receive because of our priest's personality
should be our 10 things
or should we say that the requirements are subtracted from the third party?  I
thought I'd be able to figure it out by looking at this for a few months, but there are too many issues and it's too
big,
so I'm not sure if I keep looking at
it.  Something
like this is now called Steve, a diss point. So, from Mocha
to the dj code, the ski farm has that function, that is, when skipping,
but this had a lot of problems.
You know ,
how far will skip if it is skiing before and after , baby , now it is
not consistent  If you
dig a mo show dew ski, you can go down at all. Is it skip time or not? This is
a lot if the situation is case by case.  You
uploaded it, but I can't see it from behind. It was uploaded in November 2018 at this point.
What is this?  I think it's
great to see that you continued to do it until the end, but yes, I
think there are so many
things to worry about when revising 1 now.
What kind of character should cotton have?
So, how far will the function go? I have to do something like that. If I think about that, now I have to
pay for a roadmap for my main specialty.
Yes,
and now there is a node jen lts policy.  It
becomes a political party in April every year next year. It will be in the middle of April. At that time, if I
wanted to stabilize the operation with all nodes, I would use lts, ​​and if I
wanted to use numbers more aggressively, I would now use the cont version and do it this way.
Now  Main Te Now, from the standpoint of open source with related ecosystems,
this is so good.
That's because the mocha javascript ecosystem is
swearing at nodes, so we have to support that too.
I mean, it
's just another person. Someone posted it on Twitter, and
now it's saying that open source should be treated like a product by the team I belong to, not like a product we bought.  I'll
end my presentation with 4. Thank you
[Applause]